boa tarde todo mundo é um prazer estar
aqui agradecer o convite do tejd
participar dessa edição tão especial aí
com esse foco em inovação social
tecnologia futurismo tudo que vem para o
bem aí pra promover mudança é um prazer
aqui tá com vocês pra falar sobre o
bloquinho um pouco do trabalho da gente
do que é que envolve a vida o trabalho
que acaba sendo uma coisa só
graças a deus acho que essa é uma
gratidão e também e falar de um tema que
pode ser que seja um pouco complexo mas
ao mesmo tempo ele também é muito
libertador é que é a capacidade de gerar
transformação é como a gente consegue
direcionar essa capacidade de
transformar mesmo do bloco tem porque a
gente acha que faz sentido porque a
gente acha que tem valor
então antes de entrar um pouco no
assunto queria me situar aqui também com
vocês entendem quem sabe o que é bom
quem sabe que é bitcoin pelo menos se
alguém tem algum que legal é que coisa
boa tempo está passando mesmo hoje em
dia
vocês vêem naquela na entrevista do pt
da mão esquerda deu em 2012 se não me
engano nem apareceu o bloco tinha
naquela lista das tecnologias estão
muito legal que todo mundo está sabendo
pouquinho antes de falar da palestra
ensina do toque com vocês é falar que
vai variar bastante como a gente vai
conversar aqui hoje não tem muita obra
que vai ser abstrato tem hora que vai
ser conceitual a famosa trazer alguns
exemplos para materializar pra conseguir
passar a mensagem que eu tenho aqui da
melhor forma possível para vocês
então a primeira materialização que vou
fazer hoje aqui vai ser eu
sobre mim falar um pouquinho como que eu
chego com essa energia para poder
compartilhar com você esse conteúdo
então sempre fui uma pessoa muito
inquieta assim desde pequena é colégio
no casa minha mãe meus pais sabem que
estão aqui são sempre foi muito difícil
e sempre um pouco com essência de
anarquia
de não conformidade de inquietude com
que a gente vive muito assim porque eu
tenho que aceitar a maneira que está
sendo dita hoje tiveram muitas coisas
interessantes nesse sentido acho que da
educação trazido pelas ele outras
pessoas com coisas tão interessantes que
que mostram é que a gente tem que mudar
o rumo das coisas e sempre eu carreguei
comigo essa questão empurrei é muito no
colégio conseguir até a faculdade com
ela atendendo meio que parcialmente né
paliativamente e depois na faculdade não
me formei em administração na fgv
tive o prazer de passar por alguns
processos de trainee que não
necessariamente me atenderam no que eu
queria fazer na vida
mas se tiver graça de cair no da ibm é
por último em que entrei em contato com
a tecnologia e por lá é por três anos eu
tive oportunidade de trabalhar na área
de boquim é que me trouxe um pouco desse
senso de da possibilidade que a gente
tem de criar uma nova sociedade com
novas regras com nova formatação de
acordo com o que a gente acredita
transgredindo as regras os aos termos de
negócios que já estão estabelecidos hoje
na sociedade tão engraçado a gente fala
disse mas antes visto como um socialismo
anarquia hoje a gente tem a capacidade
de dizer que a gente tem na mão uma
ferramenta propostas capitalismo em que
trabalha esses conceitos de abundância
de plenitude de economia circular
colaborativa em que enderecem se de uma
maneira que pavimenta por uma ferramenta
esses valores
então não por acaso caindo um pouco
sobre a guiné a primeira aplicação que a
gente teve conhecido é o bitcoin que no
paper que publicou ele quem é que é o
pedro pira é eletrônica que assistem
quem publicou foi o satoshi nakamoto
traz aí a perspectiva da gente tirar os
bancos né a gente conseguir fazer uma
transação financeira de pessoa para
pessoa
quebrando um pouco desse status corte é
que querendo ou não é um pouco quem
detém o poder hoje de manter a sociedade
daquela maneira que tanto me inquieta e
não por acaso a primeira aplicação que a
gente teve foi
os bancos nessa transação financeira
nessa forma do sistema mas subtil e não
é o bloquinho não foi só a primeira
aplicação que a gente teve então pra
passar dinheiro mesmo é transação
financeira em que abre nessa diferença
em um escopo gigantesco de coisas que a
gente pode fazer com essa classe com
esse protocolo do bloco que são vários
essencialmente é essencialmente o bloco
tim é pura definição pra gente ter um
piso como aqui embora todo mundo conhece
é um uma grande rede sincronizada de
transação de dados em que dividem um
banco de dados único compartilhado
sincronizado que cada um tem sua copa e
traz pra gente uma série de vantagens na
na relação com um negócio com qualquer
tipo de relacionamento com pessoas não é
que nem ficou claro na economist em 2015
será então um pouco depois do fim do
toque do peter ó é que a tecnologia por
trás do bloco do bitcoin que tinha
capacidade de transformar o mundo então
como que isso pode trazer pra gente essa
maior confiança nas relações essa maior
transparência como kiss de fato pode
mudar o mundo além do bitcoin tão
rapidamente assim só pra gente só pra
ficar materializado no que eu falo um
pouquinho do kit um dos exemplos de
casas que vão trazer aqui
que que é isso na verdade é que essa
rede esse banco de dados distribuídos
ele tem um principal conceito quatro
deles que eu vou trazer rapidamente um é
distribuída então aquele livro razão que
a gente tem nossa contabilidade em que a
gente faz transferência a nota coisa que
passou de um para o outro ele está
distribuído e compartilhado que nem como
é que vocês com todo mundo então isso é
um ponto positivo mas poxa estou
compartilhando que com quem será que
isso é prejudicial para mim na minha
economia no negócio aqui tem critérios
de privacidade em que eu estabeleço
através de algoritmos de criptografia
exatamente o que eu quero compartilhar
com as pessoas
não tem coisa que é interessante tem
coisa que não é isso eu estabeleço na
hora que o que eu coloco meus esmaltes e
contras que são os termos dos negócios
as regras dos de negócios que eu vou
executar essa rede
então lá eu coloco quais são os termos
por exemplo
hoje empresta um real um tanto de tempo
se não me devolver tentar juros e isso é
alto e executado as coisas acontecem de
maneira automática
por isso queria um contrato inteligente
e como isso é validada de que maneira
que essas transações acontece existe um
consenso entre todos os participantes na
rede que esse consenso faz a validação
de que esses morte contra estão
acontecendo de maneira harmônica que
realmente estão atendendo às
características de todo mundo que está
participando da rede de maneira
eficiente
então dessa forma estabeleça uma visão
do dessa dessa plataforma transnacional
que é o bloco tinha que dá pra gente
fazer muita coisa com isso as principais
que a gente tem hoje é a que num toque
rápido são as privadas e as públicas
entre as privadas ou vai perder é bem
interessante em que você é inscreve
players que são conhecidos então são
pessoas que você sabe atores que estão
claramente é denominado né isso cabe
muito para o setor privado então
empresas retiram no caso que é um
protocolo público é que as pessoas podem
pessoas normais nunca ser uma empresa
para entrar bitcoin que usa mesmo
protocolo de detido o mesmo modelo de
consenso e estela que está aparecendo em
novo bem legal para facilitar pagamento
com menos taxa menos custo mais
agilidade com o smart contras mais
reduzidos específicos para transações
porque eu tô falando das coisas um pouco
meu técnico e com vocês porque eu quero
que realmente eles entendam como que
isso pode gerar um impacto tão uma
primeira ação é de impacto social quem
está trabalhando é em conseguir rastrear
doação 1 por exemplo é eu tenho toda
essa cadeia é que está interligada de
maneira automatizada transparente
imutável com confiança
poxa que bacana seria se eu pudesse
conseguir acompanhar as doações que são
feitas hoje em dia acho que a maioria
das pessoas que não dou é porque não
confia em campo eu vou doar não sei se
um dia vai chegar num tem essa certeza
então com um bloquinho nessa rede
permissionado que a rede privada de
empresas com atores bem conhecidas que
não tinha falado a gente pode nessa
solução que está desenvolvendo por
exemplo chama we light
a gente rastrear as doações que são
feitas através de compras online
então eu instalo nesse caso um plugin no
meu no meu browser faça uma compra entre
mais de mil e tantas lojas parceiras que
a gente tem
nessa compra em vez de eu ganhar um
desconto que vai voltar pra minha conta
corrente eu tenho opção de direcionar
esse dinheiro por uma doação e aí eu
escolho qual onde eu quero dentro da
zona de s next os objetivos
desenvolvimento sustentável da onu tem
17 lá eu escolho uma por exemplo que é
erradicar a pobreza me aparece o leque
de ongs eu escolho uma aquele desconto
que eu gerei naquela compra pelo
mecanismo vai ser rastreado e acompanhar
seu ver vai sair o dinheiro na minha
conta
vai passar pela loja vai chegar na light
vai chegar na ong
então dessa maneira a gente criou uma
rede que é o dita sem a necessidade de
confiar num intermediário único que
aquele dinheiro está chegando um caso
muito parecido que é o da moeda que foi
o primeiro vai se unir no brasil acie um
é curioso saber que é como se fosse um
iptu neckel inicial com off então por
uma empresa abriu o capital no caso do
blog ela pode e fazer uma oferta de
dinheiro de fundy internacional e esse
foi o primeiro caso no brasil é curioso
porque é muito similar então ele
funciona também para fazer
microfinanciamento que é isso né eu
pretendo um produtor no caso aqui em vez
de ongs são cooperativas estão muito bem
mapeadas e tudo isso para ilustrar o
como que a gente pode gerar um impacto
social assertivo mesmo assim a gente
fala não isso realmente eu sei o quanto
está mudando
então por exemplo no caso é esse projeto
tinha um mapeamento muito rico feito
pela unicap de todas as cooperativas no
brasil a maioria delas pelo menos
e esse e esse projeto é criou um token
pela plataforma de tiro um então que eu
comentei aberto público que gerou um
token como se fosse bitcoin só que
baseado na etnia que chama mda
as pessoas podem comprar e citou que
está listado na sext esse toque e
direcionar isso para cooperativas ou
cooperados
então nós investem elas fazem um micro
financiamento do estoque para esses
projetos que acontece as pessoas vão lá
usam esse dinheiro fazem o projeto que
elas disseram que
o que fazer no acesso e tudo mais geram
receita gera um valor com aquele
dinheiro e devolve esse dinheiro para um
investidor com uma taxa de retorno e
mais um relatório de impacto que foi
feito precisamente às assertivo na hora
que a pessoa recebeu aquele dinheiro
para receber esse dinheiro meu amigo
você vai ter que atender tal e tal
índice tal e tal índice baseado em tal e
tal ds e então sim você vai receber o
dinheiro não lhe devolve o investimento
junto com o relatório de impacto e
devolve como devolve no blog então é
imutável é confiável e transparente a
gente tem certeza do que está melhorando
em que aspecto que está melhorando assim
é num panorama pouco mais amplo é um
relatório bem legal quem se interessar e
feito pela estampa de como que o botinha
pode realmente gerar um impacto social
disruptivo totalmente e ao longo dos
anos a gente vê o quanto está crescendo
as aplicações de boquim é nadine um
profissinal academia que basicamente
horizonte de 2015 para 2016 assim como
teve um boom gigantesco então é
realmente recente né confirmou que tinha
comentado no começo mas é muito
inspirador assim e tem grandes
organizações que já estão trabalhando
nesse sentido então por exemplo a
consciência que eu faço parte do grupo
de mentoria para o bloco tinha na
aplicação de impacto social consciência
maior empresa do mundo de
desenvolvimento de tião que aquele
protocolo aberto público que eu comentei
com vocês para aplicar o que tinha então
eles fazem soluções e tem uma área só de
impacto social
então é muito legal porque você vê o que
áreas que estão sendo contempladas o que
realmente está se gerando de resultado
de toda essa tecnologia
e aí entra num slide que eu gosto muito
e eu que fiz há problema mas é que me
inspira muito assim porque eu acho que
pega um pouco do que a gente está
falando todo mundo junto né que é dessa
nova economia na china e os protocolos
que a gente conversou antes também né
público empresa lina que essa nova
economia que a gente está vivendo e tão
bem o pessoal falou né e
do ptran ela é totalmente colaborativa
não é compartilhada circular resiliente
de baixo carbono a gente está vivendo
uma nova era mesmo o que prova que prega
por uma economia de abundância de outra
perspectiva
pensando no blog shopping a gente tem
ali na população sendo contemplada por
protocolos abertos públicos que retiram
empresas rai peled entre outros que de
uma certa maneira vão se encontrar daqui
a pouco nesses protocolos e conversam
então por que então daqui a pouco a
gente não vai estar tendo que nem a
gente já tem alguns exemplos por exemplo
gtd que é grandes é cadeias de logística
trabalhando em um blog independente da
empresa protocolos por indústrias que
vão estar sendo trabalhados por
indústria cruzando-se e porque não daqui
a pouco por governos se você for ver na
estônia tem altíssima as aplicações de
boxe e na suíça emitisse e rigidez tudo
por votla existe um avanço muito maior e
porque daqui a pouco não quem sabe 2021
pouco depois que nem o próprio renan
caso fala a gente não tem um globo
totalmente cruzado numa cadeia de
transação confiável em que as pessoas
confiam nas que está acontecendo nem que
a política está além do que a gente acha
então assim
isso me traz uma inspiração muito grande
e coloca o bloco tinha também uma
posição é de colaboração no bloco tinha
só que vai resolver tudo isso ele
precisa das outras coisas
então por exemplo para entrar uma
informação no bloquinho a gente tá
falando a depois que está lá tudo certo
né traz imutável é seguro e tudo mais e
mais e pra entrar a informação será que
a pessoa que colocou informação lá tava
com a melhor das intenções ela pode por
uma coisa errada
então a idéia também é que a gente tenha
a notícia é que a internet das coisas
sensores espalhados por essa rede para
que a informação que entre entre de
maneira fidedigna
então vamos supor que por exemplo tem
uma pesagem uma cadeia de logística que
eu falei que vai entrar uma tonelada de
grão de soja e esse é o primeiro input
uma pessoa vai escrever e depois disso
vai seguir na cadeia automaticamente
mas essa parte depende de alguém puxa
porque não tem uma balança inteligente e
uma foto não de
o cone sul e que os dois juntos 50
aquele peso na balança reporta
directamente para o nó
nessa base teve gente o qual é o peso ea
foto confirmando que é mil
uma tonelada de soja não é de cacau
confronto entrou d'adda entrou um dado
certo na rede depois então ele segue
fluido e à saída desse dado também pode
ser um calcanhar-de-aquiles né a gente
tem hoje a distribuição não é nem
pensando nessa soja que entrou virou um
produto um alimento a distribuição pode
ser feita por um caminho inteligente ou
então na perspectiva de varejo por um
drone
nem tão assim a gente feche a cadeia de
uma maneira complementar né ea
computação cognitiva para que como que
entra aí os contratos estão inscritos né
inteligentes mas não cognitivas percebe
que é smart contract e se cair uma ponte
no meio do caminho o o caminho é a hora
de a para b mas agora tem um tornado no
meio do b e agora puxa tem que ter um
parâmetro sutil que conversa com as
regras do negócio escrito no contrato
que vai dizer não para o caminho ideal é
pra cá né então combinando essas três
coisas a gente meio que cria um
organismo vivo percebe em que a gente
direceu nele pra onde a gente achar que
deve como direcionar para onde essa
capacidade de segurança pra onde a gente
quer direcionar é essa grande força de
decisão e transformação que a gente tem
pra mim me ressoa muito é essa
possibilidade de gerar impacto direto e
construir essa sociedade nova que se
possa capitalismo fundamentado nas suas
forças
eu acho que a grande ideia que era mais
provocar vocês né e ver como que isso
dentro de vocês reflete na qual que é o
fractal zinho aí dentro de cada um e é
basicamente isso
obrigado